because i was robbing diamonds
diamonds is you know people said why'd
you ride diamonds why don't you rob a
bank well the money's with the diamonds
there's no money in a bank you mean like
it's not like the movies you go in there
no
[ __ ] balls
the only thing they have they have
depots i used to know cruz they used to
rob depots depos is where they keep the
money to go to the banks
like the wells fargo depot might have 30
million 50 million
you need to track the trailer and the
guy who knows how to drive it take 30
percent you get let's see you robin i
got 30 of those diamonds it's a [ __ ]
lot of money how are you gonna put 40
[ __ ] million dollars
in [ __ ] pallets or [ __ ] and try to
get it out and wait you know you'd need
[ __ ] trucks yeah
diamonds you could put a hundred [ __ ]
30 million in a [ __ ] up your ass if
you want
that's what you're into
that's how you hide them to get them to
the airport but that's something
really
going to the airport i'm already nervous
at the airport